not only that all right this is this is  where it gets crazy the marquee of death  alright not only did he like distort  reality and screw up dr doom's mind to  make him believe six weeks had passed  all right he grabs doctor doom he turns  his heart to stone turns his blood to  acid opens up a time portal and throws  him 65 million years into the past i've  never seen anything like that before  the only time i ever saw anything like  that was during uh during the infinity  gauntlet story and that was thanos  wielding the infinity stones so the  marquee of death is like okay look like  if doctor doom was not able to beat the  fantastic four then i'm gonna be the one  to defeat them and then i'm gonna kill  him